Harvey Weinstein cut the last link to
the management of his former media
empire as the sex scandal widens the
disgraced movie mogul resigned yesterday
from the board of directors of The
Weinstein Company he had retained his
board seat despite being fired last week
from running day-to-day operations and
this morning his brother Bob Weinstein
is also facing a sexual harassment
allegation bianna golodryga shows us how
the scandal could enter a damaging new
phase for The Weinstein Company Jana
good morning actually legally damaging
new phase for the company good morning
Weinstein called in his resignation
reportedly from a treatment facility in
Arizona he has apologized for his past
hurtful behavior but denies engaging in
any non-consensual sex nearly 60 women
now accuse him of misconduct ranging
from sexual harassment to rape whatever
stands in our way Lena Headey plays a
ruthless Queen on HBO's Game of Thrones
but says she felt powerless when Harvey
Weinstein allegedly tried to force her
into his hotel room
Weinstein whispered in my ear don't tell
anyone about this not your manager not
your agent she shared on Twitter I got
into my car and I cried on Tuesday The
Weinstein Company Board ratified its
decision to fire Weinstein a formality
given that he resigned from the board
that same day his ouster legal experts
say does not protect the company from
potential lawsuits it is going to be the
age-old question what did the company
know and when did it know it allegations
of harassment across Hollywood are
growing Amazon Studios chief Roy price
resigned following an accusation of
sexual harassment actress Reese
Witherspoon speaking at an event in Los
Angeles revealed that she was assaulted
by an unnamed director when she was 16
on Tuesday television producer Amanda
Siegel told variety that she was
harassed by Harvey's brother Bob Bob
Weinstein was genuinely abusive with
people in my company and Jeffrey
Katzenberg the brothers former boss at
Disney said Bob belittled and bullied
his employees the one person who did
reveal himself in an unacceptable way to
me was in fact Bob Bob Weinstein's
lawyer told CBS this morning variety
story about Bob Weinstein is riddled
with false and misleading assertions by
miss Siegel and we have the emails to
prove it he did not respond to a
question about Katzenberg's comments
though it does raise questions as to
whether Bob Weinstein will remain at the
company if in fact they are acquired by
Colony Capital and also it broadens the
discussion beyond just the corridors of
The Weinstein Company to others within
the industry gets uglier and uglier
thank you very much bianna